il n'a peut-être l'air de rien comme ça
de bon matin et pourtant françoisaro est
un esthète et comme un esète il séci les
bonnes
chosesauit deç
biemp VI jeune qui pas longtempsire vite
sont hyper fr super
bon Natur mais cet artiste n'a pas fait
que goûter au plaisir de la bouche en
vérité cet homme est un boul de la
[Musique]
vie 15 an de
carrièreis pas
arêle dans son entre quel part dans les
hauteurs de
paricienis jouer d'une vtaine
d'inruments
différents de barbarie accordéon guitare
et même un exemplaire de la tromécnue
d'ulcimè de violons évidemment diverses
et variés puis cimè qui est typique d'un
instrument qui est né en Europe de l'Est
et aussi dans les vauges c'est la
famille de l'épinette des vauges qui en
traversant l'Atlantique en allant dans
les appalages s'est transformé en
dciimère au total depuis 1984 cet
artiste hors norme aura participé à 18
albums v au côté de r des garçons bouch
il aura donné quelques 900 concerts de
par le
[Musique]
monde mais c'est au fond de cette cour
parisienne que françiszaro investit
aussi beaucoup de son énergie boucherie
production est une maison de disque à
l'image de son créateur vaste et
colorée il faut croire que ça plaît 150
albums ont été produits et les cassettes
continuent d'affuer ça dépend des jours
sur l'année donc c'est 1200 après ça
fait à peu près moyen de TR par jour
quoi les groupes véritables ils ont les
artistes véritables ils savent plus
tropù signer donc n reçoit énormément de
choses maisainçit même du classique du
jazz parce que les gens savent plus où
signer compris même des certaines
références qui savent plus trouver une
maison de
disque dans la depuis 15 ans qu'elle
tourne entre maison de disque et
carrière solo la petite entreprise de
François n'est pas prête
[Musique]
de Gliss L le long du comptoir par
terre